Carrusel de las artes
[Música]
María Carolina piña
un placer que estén nuevamente en
nuestra compañía hoy en Carrusel de las
artes vamos a hablarles de las ventas
por subastas un sector que no conoce la
crisis al contrario las casas de
subastas de obras de arte en Francia
registraron cifras históricas el año
pasado así que nosotros quisimos saber
cómo se realizan esas ventas por subasta
y para ello recibimos hoy en nuestros
estudios a Olga de marcio de la casa
arcurial Hola Olga encantada de tenerte
con nosotros Hola Buenos días María
Carolina gracias por recibirme estoy muy
contenta y
lista para presentar a curian bueno y
justamente arkuri es una de las casas de
venta por subastas más importantes de
Francia tú trabajas en acurrial Mónaco
cuéntanos Qué tipo de objetos ponen
ustedes en venta en subastas Bueno mira
te voy a presentar rápidamente arcuria
nace en el 2002 por que fue creada por
junto a él los con los subastadores
Francis Bridge el ridícula y Emilio en
el 2005 efectivamente nos convertimos en
la casa francesa de subastas más
importante y ya desde el 2006 empezamos
a hacer las ventas también en Mónaco que
las hacemos dos veces al año estamos
presentes en varios países la sede
central está aquí en París pero estamos
presentes también en Alemania en Austria
en Italia en Bélgica en Mónaco y en
Marruecos Bueno y cuando hablamos de
ventas por subasta siempre tenemos en
mente los cuadros o el arte plástico
pero también hay otros muchos objetos
que pueden ser objetos de ventas por
subastas totalmente Mira nosotros
tenemos 26 departamentos o sea no es
solo arte Obviamente el arte tiene un
espacio muy importante porque hablamos
de tenemos departamentos que digamos que
según a según de cada cada periodo
tenemos el departamento de arte antigua
el departamento de arte moderna del arte
contemporánea arte Ultra contemporáneo
después Tenemos también por el arte de
por el estilo digamos o sea puede ser
arte asiática Oriental o sea tenemos una
una variedad una variedad muy importante
en desde el punto de vista del arte pero
también vendemos muebles antiguos
muebles modernos como de design digamos
de Ártico Tenemos también un
departamento que vende vinos un
departamento que que promueve las joyas
los relojes tenemos una variedad enorme
tenemos las monedas tenemos los
manuscritos los libros es extremadamente
variado y y extremadamente
interesante tenemos en cada departamento
expertos a disposición para poder dar
una Una valoración para cada objeto
organizamos
días de valoraciones jornadas de
valoraciones que permite a las personas
acercarse a nosotros y dar un valor a
los objetos que ellos desean después
poner a la venta y justamente Cómo
llegan esos objetos a ustedes para luego
colocarlos en una venta por subasta Mira
las motivaciones pueden vender por
varios motivos y no siempre es un motivo
económico no es que la gente decide
Bueno voy a vender porque necesito no
muchas veces es una cuestión de cambio
de gusto de cambio de querer cambiar la
decoración de su casa o que ya uno
cambió el gusto ya este cuadro no me
gusta o que por ejemplo muchas personas
tienen joyas en una en una caja fuerte
pero De hecho no las utilizan entonces Y
además que estamos en un periodo donde
la ecología es muy importante y hemos
cambiado nuestros nuestros hábitos y
tenemos menos tendencia acumular
Entonces es más fácil desprenderse de
nuestros objetos Entonces es las
personas podían cambiar o dicen Bueno
voy a ponerlo a la venta y quizás me
compro algo a lo que le doy más utilidad
en vez de dejarlo guardado en un armario
una caja fuerte Olga y ahí artículos o
obras de arte para todos los
presupuestos para todos los tipos de
públicos que puede haber totalmente
nosotros nos hemos democratizado
muchísimo tenemos varios tipos de ventas
ciertas ventas de mucho prestigio que se
que se efectúan en salas de venta pero
también desde hace algunos años hemos
creado estas ventas 100% online que les
permite a las personas que también con
un presupuesto menos elevado tienen la
posibilidad de adquirir cosas que tienen
un cierto valor no como por ejemplo en
el arte tenemos los múltiplos con las
joyas o los relojes relojes o joyas que
tienen un valor menos importante pero
digamos que le damos la posibilidad a
todo el mundo de poder acceder y poder
comprarse un objeto de valor bonito no Y
ahora cómo se llevan a cabo las subastas
porque tengo entendido que son públicas
y que justamente cuando ustedes
organizan una venta pues la gente puede
ir a ver los artículos que están en
venta y percibirlos verlos incluso
tocarlos o informarse sobre esos objetos
totalmente nosotros empezamos digamos el
primer paso es organizar es hacer un
catálogo que permite ver los objetos con
una estimación
las personas pueden venir a ver
organizamos días de exposición que duran
más o menos dos tres días la gente puede
venir
cuando las hacemos en París las
exposiciones Generalmente son en París
cuando las hacemos en Mónaco se hacen en
Mónaco las personas se pueden acercar
pueden ver y la posibilidad también
existe de poder hacer todo desde lejos o
sea online pero también por teléfono
nosotros accedemos damos el acceso a las
personas con una línea telefónica y que
pueden participar a la venta desde lejos
y pueden informarse tenemos lo que se
llama report de cada objeto y si alguien
quiere saber más En qué estado está el
objeto nosotros damos todas estas
informaciones para justamente facilitar
a las personas que no tienen la
seguridad que quieren o no quieren
comprar tengan la seguridad de todo lo
que compran estaba bueno en buenas
condiciones bueno Y para para que
nuestro público pueda conocer más Cómo
se lleva a cabo justamente
una subasta los vamos a invitar al salón
retro móvil 2023 de París Allí se
realizó una venta gigante de vehículos
de colección justamente organizada por
arcurial y a continuación nuestro
reportaje en esa subasta
[Música]
el ambiente estuvo eléctrico en el salón
móvil a Cuando comenzó la subasta de
vehículos de colección 200 carros de
carrera deportivos antiguos de lujo y
hasta un barco que perteneció a Jean
Paul belmondo estaban en venta ante los
ojos de coleccionistas y curiosos
especialista de asal motocards
hay precisamente 240 lotes que cubren
buena parte de la historia de los
motores desde carros tirados por
caballos hasta un proyecto de cohete
diseñado por reno pensando en lo que
sería el carro en el año
2338 Así que es una colección muy basta
vehículos de firmas históricas Bugatti
Mercedes Jaguar Porsche automóviles con
una historia y a veces anécdotas que
pueden hacer variar la estimación de su
valor
[Música]
muy complicado reposa sobre factores muy
objetivos la rareza del modelo su estado
general los elementos originales que
tiene pero también hay factores
subjetivos un barco que perteneció a un
actor como belmondo puede hacer que el
precio se duplique o se triplique
una venta como ésta representa 12 meses
de trabajo hay carros que hemos buscado
o negociado desde hace años en general
vendemos el 80% de los lotes tenemos
compradores y vendedores en Estados
Unidos Australia y coleccionistas
europeos esta colección por ejemplo
viene de Holanda es un mercado
internacional con clientes que vienen a
ser transacciones en París
le preguntamos a Antoine un vehículo con
características excepcionales puede
considerarse una obra de arte
Claro que sí por supuesto Hay carros que
tiene una línea perfecta son una obra de
arte mecánica si uno abre el capó de un
Ferrari por ejemplo y ve el nivel de
detalle con el que está armado el chasis
el motor B12 es una pieza de orfebrería
un vehículo puede ser una obra de arte Y
más si es de una rareza excepcional
y seguimos en nuestros estudios en
compañía de Olga de marzo de arcurial
Olga lo vimos justamente en ese salón al
cual ustedes nos invitaron gentilmente
los motores también son artículos que
desatan pasiones totalmente Bueno aquí
se vio efectivamente
la energía que hay en este salón y pues
tenemos muchos apasionados de carros de
automóviles Y en este caso tenemos una
variedad enorme porque podemos hablar de
carros modernos como de automóviles
antiguos entonces
y el retro móvil es como es un salón
Entonces tenemos de un lado a las
personas que vienen a comprar otros que
vienen a curiosear a informarse Y pues
la venta y cómo funciona una venta pues
la gente primero obtiene el catálogo Se
informa después se inscribe no hay que
inscribirse a la venta
hay la posibilidad como ya dije de estar
presente o de hacer esto de distancia a
Y entonces el el
subastador empieza a pasar lotes de un
lote al próximo y al final lo
interesante de todo esto es que es el
mercado que decide no somos nosotros
Nosotros vamos a dar una estimación como
lo dijo justamente Antoine es un trabajo
muy minucioso y y que necesita de un
experto pero al mismo tiempo es el
mercado que va a decir cuánto está
dispuesto a pagar por tal objeto Y eso
es el lado así de no de interesante
aventuroso de de las subastas
totalmente y también de entender después
Cuáles son las tendencias qué es lo que
va en el momento que es lo que no va y
todo es muy cíclico porque quizás en un
momento va después uno lo vuelve a
proponer y y no fue Entonces es algo muy
apasionante no y bueno las personas así
deciden y el Que obviamente
lleva la el precio Lo más alto es el que
al final se lleva el objeto no con mucha
felicidad y también yo pienso que la
persona que compra por una subasta esto
otra experiencia que comprar en una
tienda no porque es es la guerra es
decir yo lo quiero y yo voy a voy a
ganar esto también hay un estrés porque
la gente dirá Bueno yo puedo llegar
hasta un cierto precio y ya de Más allá
de ahí no puedo pasar totalmente y hay
personas que si de lejos no quieren el
teléfono no quieren online porque no no
manejan todavía muy bien lo digital
ofrecemos también que pongan una oferta
hasta la cual máximo pueden llegar y
hasta ahí después ellos deciden de
pararse y obviamente hay personas que
están dispuestas muchas veces a pagar
mucho más de lo que uno puede o desea no
bueno Olga te agradecemos muchísimo
haber venido a nuestro programa Carrusel
de las artes para hablarnos de ese mundo
magnífico que es el de las ventas por
subastas que como tú lo decías es
impredecible pero muy eléctrico no así
que muchísimas gracias por haber venido
desde Mónaco hasta nuestros estudios y a
todos ustedes Muchísimas gracias por su
sintonía Esperamos que hayan aprendido
un poco más de las ventas por subastas
aquí con nosotros hasta pronto
[Música]